hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to alice is dead part 3 now
this is a totally different style in
what was happening in the last two games
and like each of them were a different
theme from the get-go so I'm very
interested to see what's gonna happen in
this one because I don't understand
anything to happen in the second game
other than the fact that it was like the
middle act kind of building the past
well things definitely got a little more
interesting I can smell this entire box
of crayons right here but I got my lucky
notebook and I'm ready to solve any
clues they need to be solved I've got a
phone - hey 9-1-1 hello tell me oh wait
we're sorry but all officers are
currently busy with an incident at
Wonderland jail well I was about to tell
you about that sorry my bad I will just
go now okay so I still have my bell
which is from the first game oddly
enough and I have no idea what all of
this is all about because it seems like
a No
cityscape these stones seen ancient and
mysterious whatever I'm too dark and
mysterious myself to care oh well that
was us it was a rather sudden shift text
message from Queen to all guards
disregard any falling fish the rabbit
activated oyster cloud the issue is
being dealt with oh okay the sky is I
wonder if it was that button okay okay
so is that a bomb I can't remember the
combination well I wish I could my
memory just ain't what it used to be why
go back I need to take care of the
keypad first Oh Oh the back arrow was oh
it was black I thought it would okay
nevermind I don't know why I was black I
wasn't able to see that this is an ad
for uh wait what was that what was what
whoa what was that what was that come on
do it again come on baby no all right Oh
ah god Anna come on okay I need to get
in my hideout first Oh ah screw bells
give me a brick any day okay brick right
yeah that'll take care of that it worked
with the brick crumbled Oh mom I'm just
too incredibly strong for my own rabbity
good Oh what Wow I'm strong haven't
wrote in this in a while
June 11th Maryanne got busted she took
this before she escaped nice how did
demoted Mary annie is taking direct
control the missions now he said there's
too much risk for us to be making
mistakes I'm glad she made it out of
there okay I'm not sure I could handle
prison today I was approached by the
Hatter said he had some work for me I'm
not sure if I want to take it or not job
sounds risky but what job isn't risky
these days all I know is if I get paid
I'm happy strange noises downstairs the
job went well I'm glad Alice was there
she's good with a gun but damn could she
use a knife Alice madness Returns bead
I'm not sure why the scientist needs so
many test subjects oh well I kill things
who am I to judge Hatter said if I
didn't kill Alison Queen would he said
the Queen would take his time I don't
want her to suffer I don't know what to
do I found Alice's mirror she thought
she lost it I'll have to give it
think I'm losing my mind I saw things
I've never seen before
vivid disturbing things and then in an
instant they were gone
perhaps it's stress oh well we'll all be
over soon
just this last job that's the end of it
well I can tell that things went
horribly wrong with that last job at
least my hideout looks nice I'm not
thirsty oh this isn't about thirst sir
the strength smells funny
it smells like adult fun happy juice
okay miss some calls okay I don't know
what happened but a closed shop
everything has been scrubbed and I
remained dark until I hear from you okay
was that an I'm gonna call the Hatter
first five five five eight eight eight
oh four the adder Cherokee axe sorry I
can take all right shut up shut up I
don't like you
okay and I don't know who Anne is maybe
that was the other message okay got it
got it got it Bob oh I hope she's okay
have a stain you really want gone need
to make filth or grime disappear like it
never even existed then teapot cleanness
has you covered with great service and
prices that kill if you go with anyone
else you must be mad oh okay nice pun I
don't think that's a real cleaning
company also on a very smart rabbit also
I killed Alice well that's beside the
point
all I know is that alice is dead okay so
I got those and all I know is that an
old message tax from Hatter I had to go
away for a while I told Marianne you
could use some extra help make sure you
give the Queen my regards if you see
them my Hatter okay cool thanks
so now what don't need fish okay so oh
hey oh hey what are you doing to his
brain going to have to get rid of these
two to get in I'm not sure I want to get
in the Tweedles drink we oh it's
Tweedledum and Tweedledee oh okay I got
you I didn't recognize you because you
were weird and bizarre not exactly what
I was used to okay
oh hey hey you weren't you sitting some
mushrooms peaches ah which one mushrooms
or peaches what do they do they help
take off the edge yeah
they help you relax I think I'm okay
thanks rule II oh just bring me a shiny
okay oh I'll come back you're mine my
not beaches it's the white rabbit it's
called the white rabbit and that's it
okay so I need a mushroom to put in
their drink and that's probably gonna
let me do what I need to do let's see
here oh okay that's just been wet okay
so maybe if I just WAN
you want a shiny I got a shiny for you
it's a shiny metal pipe
I can polish it up for you all right
fine whoa oh whoa well I didn't know I
could do that I guess I could have uh
what the mushroom and is drink but that
was way more efficient
I like that metal detector and said how
am I gonna what am I gonna do
oh sure through this okay I'll never
forget you metal pipe mwah just like
everything else have a hi hello glad
you're alright rabbit the queen is
definitely at the hi excuse me I'm
trying to read a message thank you thank
you thank you sir the Queen is
definitely at the club find him and kill
him this ends today stay safe and I'll
be in touch
okey-dokey then
alright this is bizarre I wonder when
the Cheshire Cat is gonna come into play
for good time then okay so that's a
number that I could call I did her I
didn't okay my fight flight six to nine
tree go this can't be good oh it might
be just good still I'm calling me oh
come on don't you want to have a good
time okay bye the bloody I waits and
waits bum rot whoa inky blew up in here
I don't know what you're talking about
ah the toilet seams loose great what
does that mean why do I care if the
toilet is loose that's a bizarre thing
to notice that's pretty music by the way
I like that soundtrack
okay there's multiple stalls that I can
go through here called toilet paper it's
for I really like toilets hey I'm just
trying to explore everything it's your
game I know I need to explore be careful
with Frank he has a gun
that was that me I don't think that's a
magical nut oh I'll just whisper my dark
secrets to it anyway
was there any pull oh there's another
number on there okay uh five five five
seven three two one long we've been in
business
I'm afraid the March Hare that's me I
ain't right now please call back during
regular business hours
I don't forget the TAS pat on you bell
recycling program if there's one thing
me really boils my biscuits
it's a bloke who carries around a pill
that he don't even need now leave a
message is my message goes green oh well
I don't believe this he made fun of my
bail I love my bail my belly bells the
best beloved the white rabbit don't eat
anything but his belly bail in this
toilet I like that loose toilet over
there but this toilet pretty good norm a
front of my bail how happy can head with
my bail just like I did twins um Andy
both of them with my bell and the
uncontrollable Bell murderer
don't you jazz on me okay maybe they're
not after my bail but I just have to be
sure okay okay there's a kitchen in here
does anyone need a bell in here I have
an excess of dead someone wanted me to
read oh hey blow that corn is that a
euphemism I'm not
you feel lucky punk
oh do I need to do this until I get
something well I feel lucky mr. Vallot
ding ding there's some fortune for me
damnit belly the things raised
there's no way to let you win it doesn't
love you like I do belly there's an I in
this world oh well let's make it very
cold in here hmm maybe I can win now
maybe now that is cold is gonna let me
win hey here we get it belly we are
something but it didn't really use
anything because it took way too long
over the bow can I use my belly belly if
I smash you against this will it open
for me there's gotta be a way barely
okay ooh now it's hot in here I don't
know what that means what does it mean
others hearts that change anything it's
getting hot in here so they can take off
all their clothes maybe not I don't know
Oh take a chance rabbit what what a lot
oh I get it because it's hot does it fog
up did someone make it fog up in here I
don't know
access granted
what do you mean access to what oh did
it say like lucky slots or something I'm
not oh whoa BAM Oh
Jabberwocky what does that even mean Oh
hey wait so I won before did I not even
need to do that i won by spamming it
what did I won what I won Delana what
did I won what did I won okay do I get a
grenade to go with my belly man hey this
doesn't make any sense it didn't give me
anything
why didn't give me the grenade I wanted
said it was supposed to be a chance take
a chance
whoa what what wait what the hell is
that why is that there that's a cool
dinosaur
it's a goddamn dinosaur laser fight oh
oh oh oh oh you believe in ghosts find
three videotapes and you will okay cool
I'm happy about this something bad
happened to dr. burr but thankfully
belly will keep me safe there's no
scarier monster than me looks like these
used to be cats
oh my kick kicking it to the mix blood
pumpkin great name if you want to take
the elevator you're going to play my
game find him watch the tapes I miss you
I miss my Oh oh is that the daughter
that I was talking to before that I let
win it oh this better not be like a full
metal alchemist situation where the
daughter was uh turned into a horrible
mother
Oh haha there we go okay so these things
are gonna be here hidden around this
place here I just got to go find them
there's possibility they might have been
in here no the magical nut is not a
magical tape there's got to be another
one around here somewhere and I'm going
to find it and I
kill it live oh okay there was one in
the trash there cool is the one in oh
hey oh that's a door hinge I thought it
was a tape it just turned out to be a
door hinge I'm a dum-dum hey peaches Oh
Oh - Oh take it and don't say I never
did anything nice for you well you
didn't give me shrooms when I need it I
had to beat someone to death because
Bailey wanted me to
that's a cram time does I say crap time
where's si Cory easy time I'll just put
these in here dr. Raymond conducting
test number three great buddha bar test
subject is unresponsive deceased test
subject number seven seemed promising
but still proved to be unstable like the
others several monitors were destroyed
before the test subject expired I feel
like we're getting close to a
breakthrough I just need more time
looks like a lot of things broke through
your chest alaria what does it mean does
it mean something good what's oh no oh
no oh no I thought it was over no your
smile is welcome
your whisper this security clean white
teeth give and why don't he is what
McLean before it tells us working
getting your teeth clean
whitening give a security McLean gives
his speech consistently white you look
clean to me okay
why so I missed the second one I thought
it was over I skipped over it what does
it mean okay I got a message rabbit I
left a present for you inside of the
club I have a sinking feeling you're
gonna need it oh the jokes oh it's so
funny I get it blop wait sink oh there
we go one how merry I got this in here
well I don't wonder why but now I have a
gun Oh see what daddy did see what they
did to Daddy I fixed the elevator for
you but I wouldn't go if I was you you
know want you to end up like Daddy well
I got a gun that'll help out with it cuz
I got Betty it's funny
me and belly are here together leave him
this how an elevator can be going up
with me and belly and I good gun Gunny
gun oh and I can still be going down
what no
beginning at the beginning go on till
you come to the end then stop what does
that even mean
is that a quote from Alice in Wonderland
oh that can't be the end I can't end
like that
god dammit Oz oh I must have something
wrong I must have done something
horribly wrong
there had to be a different way to go
about that there had to be I did
something wrong there's got to be a
different ways did God be different
lawyer I'm gonna find him hey hey hey oh
hey
oh wait was that the real end but the
rabbits dead now that's gonna sad but I
guess Alice was alive the whole time and
Alice's planted a body that doesn't make
a lot of sense Oh what the hell happened
that was bizarre and amazing it was so
weird
it was so weird but I got like a smile
stuck in my face okay I'm gonna find out
if that was actually the end I'm always
a little couple walk through to see if
there was another way to go about the
BRB okay okay apparently that is the
actual end like it was supposed to trick
you to think that going up the elevator
was the end and you did something wrong
but okay that was the end there so
anyway that was Alice's dead that was a
fun adventure like ridiculously fun I
had a great time playing then trying to
figure out the mystery of it these point
click adventures you know they can be a
little tedious with the fighting and the
peeking and the thing but all in all
that was really cool that was really
really cool so thank you everybody so
much for watching thank you for sticking
with me through these creep parts and
thank you for enjoying them and I really
hope you did let me know what you think
of these games in the comments below let
me know what other games you want me to
play I will read as many comments as I
can looking up you guys the suggestions
and letting me know what you think of
this game thank you everybody so much
for watching check out the other cool
games that I played in the annotation or
description below and as always I will
see you in the next one
okay nutritious delicious it's good
friend and I'll be good for you
keep going good